Henry Cavill's good looks and strong voice
make him a natural fit to play Superman, but
getting into godlike shape to play the Last
Son of Krypton is a superhuman feat in and
of itself.
How exactly did Cavill make himself faster
than a speeding bullet and more powerful than
a locomotive?
Let's find out.
Exclusive gym
In order to turn himself into the Man of Steel,
Henry Cavill turned to the exclusive Gym Jones
— an invite-only gym known for training
athletes, military personnel — and the cast
of 300.
Gym Jones is not your warm and cozy neighborhood
pilates studio.
The gym prides itself on having no televisions,
no machines, no mirrors, and no comfortable
places to sit.
And apparently, their walls have seen a fair
share of breakdowns — both physical and
psychological.
Pushing limits
Cavill's training regimen essentially pushed
him into the realm of the superhuman.
He explained,
"I'm training two-and-a-half hours a day,
pushing my body beyond its normal limits."
"It's not just a physical thing, it's a psychological
thing as well."
Cavill recalled to ShortList one particularly
excruciating moment with his trainer Mark
Twight, during which, Cavill said he was...
"...Doing some horrible rowing sprint thing,
and I said, 'I can't do this Mark, I can't,
I'm done,' and he said, 'No you're not, don't
listen to the lies.'
I kept on pulling and pulling until suddenly
I realized I had finished."
Strong foundation
Getting big is one thing.
Staying Superman-sized, however, is an entirely
different story.
"Yeah, well, ya know, gotta up the game every
year."
Henry Cavill's twice-daily training sessions
may have helped him get jacked, but once filming
actually started, that regimen went out the
window.
Still, the Man of Steel was able to minimize
the detrimental effects of a reduced workout
regimen, thanks to the ultra-solid muscle
base he'd built.
Twight explained,
"Stable fitness requires a wide, solid foundation.
The deeper that foundation, the more stable
that condition will be, and the easier it
is to maintain."
Catching Z's
Before Cavill even started training, Twight
laid down one extremely important stipulation
— the actor needed to get nine to ten hours
of sleep every single night for five months.
Twight explained to Muscle & Fitness,
"If you don't get the sleep, if you can't
recover, then we can't continue with this
training and we won't achieve the objective."
"The HGH and testosterone secretion that happens
during these deep-sleep cycles is super-important."
The tailpipe
Cavill's trainer highly recommends ending
any Superman workout with something he likes
to call "the tailpipe," which was given its
name because, as Twight says, quote, "when
you're done, it feels like you've been sucking
on the tailpipe of a car."
Basically, you row 250 meters at full speed,
then hold two 24 kilogram kettlebells in the
rack position, and repeat three times.
After that, your lungs will certainly feel
the burn — but you'll be able to get more
out of each subsequent workout, thanks to
the increased lung capacity and stamina.
Can't skip cardio
Many people looking to bulk up don't get in
enough cardio, which does a lot more than
just make you faster than a speeding bullet.
Cavill's strength coach Michael Blevins explained
to Men's Fitness,
"There's a misconception that cardio will
negatively impact muscle.
A larger work capacity can allow you to train
harder and longer.
Building muscle without conditioning is akin
to having an impressive engine without a gas
tank — it's worthless."
Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu
One of Cavill's favorite ways to stay in shape
is by practicing Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu.
However, the actor doesn't just dabble in
the martial art.
He trains with the best.
Cavill frequently takes lessons from 10-time
Jiu-Jitsu world champion Roger Gracie.
In an Instagram post, he wrote,
"My B.J.J. has slipped by the wayside a bit
with my focus being on work but it's now time
to get back into it!
Such an enjoyable way to train."
Chow down
While training to become Superman, Cavill
would generally eat between 3,500 and 5,000
calories per day, including regular post-workout
shakes.
He explained,
"You've got to eat protein first, then a little
bit of carbs.You've gotta keep your hunger
levels going."
"Unfortunately, Guinness is what I crave.
It's not ideal for six pack abs."
Getting 5,000 calories meant roughly six meals
per day.
HenryCavill.org lists samples of the 3,500
and 5,000 calorie meal plans on their "Man
of Steel Workout and Diet" page.
Strength of character
Anyone can hire some skilled personal trainers
and put down a bunch of calories to get ripped,
but playing Superman requires more than simply
lifting heavy objects and exhibiting lightning
speed.
Being Superman requires inner strength.
Twight told Muscle & Fitness,
"Genuine accomplishment looks and feels different.
It cannot be faked.
By doing physically difficult things, by changing
his body of his own will, Henry changed his
attitude and his bearing.
He looked huge.
He walked huge.
His attitude broadcast his physical capability."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!